uh alex is on the line alex how are you
hi chris how are you doing oh buddy i'm
focused and not finished how are you
today
um i'm doing good so uh i got a quick
question for you
um i uh we just started a business about
a year and a half ago
and the business is doing great uh we're
good we're
i mean it's just two months in and we're
projecting it
maybe tripling what we did last year um
things are well but
i've gotta i've got a kind of dilemma
because
all these people keep coming to me like
hey man you guys need to apply for this
ppp money
there's like money everybody else is
getting all this money
you know i know a realtor friend they
got twenty seven thousand dollars
this person's getting twenty thousand
dollars like all the stuff
and i've got two philosophies on it like
i've got no problem
finding every single tax deduction to
keep the money away from the fees right
but again on the other side of it is
is this a handout because
i'm not looking for a handout i'm i'm
looking to keep the money that i earn
right i'm not looking for the government
to to give me money that i don't deserve
right and so all these people tell me
like well you know
everybody else is doing it everybody
else why don't you do see
yeah and i'm sitting here thinking like
um um
you only have principles when it matters
like you show your true character when
it matters
and is this a handout or is this like
getting tax money back right you know
okay i just need to
let me let me tell me this what line of
work are you in
um plumbing you're in plumbing and how
many team members do you have
three and you said business you opened a
year and a half ago business
is not just doing well it's doing great
you're saying you're about to triple
your
your profits your in your uh revenue
from from from a year and a half ago is
that correct
right okay and business has been good
for you
so i'm gonna tell you this this ppp loan
this and i'm glad you called it a loan
because that's exactly what it is
people started calling it a grant people
started calling x y and z here's the
reality
the role of that money for this loan
which you and i both know
alex alone is something you pay back uh
with this it could be used for rent it
could be used for
paying your team members there were
specific things it could be used for
here's the issue people are just now
following through and trying to
submit to find out how much of this is
actually going to be forgiven
and then how much they're going to owe
so i'm going to i'm going to tell you
this
a lot of the people that are telling you
and that are are hyped up about hey
got this free money first of all number
one it wasn't free it was a loan
and the amount of paperwork they're
having to jump through right now
i'm going to tell you something they've
got a rude awakening happening
because people are submitting these and
from what i've heard from at least four
of my banker friends
on average about 45 of them are being
declined
which means that people are now gonna
start to get the payment
uh plan that they're gonna need for this
money so
if i'm you i'm avoiding this like the
plague uh
even when businesses were calling in
during the pandemic and talking about it
i was trying to let
advise them do everything but this like
this is not something that is ever going
to go away so if you owe the money
you owe it to the government uh they'll
take as long as they have to
to come get it or or come after you so
it's not something i'd advise and i
i love his his heart on principle
right yeah so you find yourself out on
an island right when you start looking
around
and this is this is not just about
people this is about anything right i've
got this principle that
i want to work real hard and if i need
help i'm going to ask for it i don't
need any help but everyone else is just
taking this it's a free fall i'm an
idiot here
right am i missing out yeah what am i
what am i doing here
and his his heart has i've got a
principle
that says i don't borrow money i
work really hard and i keep i want to
keep what's mine fair
right and that's it
yeah so should i go ahead and violate my
principles because everyone else is
no yeah no no right i really wouldn't
and and the mindset around it again of
you're having to submit paperwork to
find out how much of this is going to be
forgiven
or what your bill is going to be and
let's be honest men
we don't have this money to be loaning
what do you mean we as we the people do
not have this money to be loaning
it doesn't exist and so we're going to
pay it back
soon no it's the government we're all
going to pay it back later we print it
we just print more
christopher no i know listen to me it's
a problem you're all going to have to
pay this
it's a problem it's a it is a problem
whenever you start adding billions and
trillions with the t
yes to the bottom line and we're doing
it with the stroke of a pin
that's going to be a problem we're going
we're going to
have to that bill is coming it's coming
and you know who's going to pay for it
my kids all of us my grandkids yeah
all of us people who had no role in this
no participation in this are going to be
on the hook for it
because i couldn't say no yeah because i
couldn't have hard conversations i
couldn't live within my means
and are there people across this country
struggling holy smokes yes
right without a doubt i'm all about
helping my neighbor
yes but when good folks like this say am
i crazy for
living within my means right no or that
you had businesses that
were making millions upon millions
applying for this
ppp loan it's like come on people wake
up
get a grip